here we go
pft props philip lindsay new uh or
holdover member of the denver broncos
asked about a new member of the team
melvin gordon and what fuels philip
lindsay now that gordon is there here's
lindsay from earlier this week
i mean honestly i've had the same fire
my whole time from first time i stepped
here until now
you know uh i don't need another man
to fuel my fire you know i know what i
want
uh for my family and that's what fuels
me so for me honestly like nothing
changes you know i go out there and i i
produce when my number is called i make
big plays like i always have and i go
from there
phillip lindsey's been a great running
back for the denver broncos undrafted
lived with his parents at least
initially because he's from the uh the
denver area but now melvin gordon's in
with his big of a free agent contract as
you're going to see a running back yet
nowadays when he changes teams over
under combined scrimmage yards for
lindsay and gordon this year chris is 2
300 what do you got more or less i i got
to go under there i mean they certainly
have the talent to challenge that i'm
not you know trying to deny that because
lindsay is got two rockets up his butt
he's a home run hitter he's phenomenal
in the past game the screen game melvin
gordon is much better running back than
he gets a credit for nationally i mean
he is a specimen he is a little bit of a
home run hitter himself while being more
of a bell cow you know can smash it up
in there for a tough four and five yards
at a time to type a guy but
i think what would i would go with the
under is there's just too many other
weapons on the offense to think that
like it's all just going to be
formulated around him you know this is
not the west coast offense we're going
to get the ball to todd gurley a bunch
or alvin kamara
or anything like that you know those
offenses have these niche in their
playbooks where they can like have a
million different ways and not to say
pat shurmur and the broncos won't have
that but uh man jerry judy cortland
sutton noah fan kj hamler you know
there's there's a lot to go around here
so that's why i would go under more than
anything
yeah i'm gonna lean under as well and
i'm really curious just to see which of
those two guys steps up as the main guy
or whether it will be a a straight
rotation committee approach lindsay has
been really good but you know you don't
spend the money on melvin gordon if you
think lindsay is the guy long term and
lindsay's had some health issues and the
thing about lindsay you know we had the
the video yesterday of leonard fournette
and and we remarked on just what a giant
he is philip lindsay just looks like an
average guy i mean he's in good shape
he's in football shape but when we had
him at the super bowl a year and a half
ago there's there's not a whole lot to
him which makes you wonder
is he going to be durable over the long
haul in the national football that's a
it's a real question there's no doubt
yeah he's a he's your typical you know
third down running back that's what he
is he's really a guy that in the old
days you wouldn't even think about
giving him bell cow type carries but
that's not the way it goes in the nfl
right now he
i know a lot of people went ooh this
might be a detractor or a bad thing for
a philip lindsay with melvin gordon
there he should be very happy he really
should let melvin gordon go up in there
and smash his body around save yourself
a little your payday is coming here real
soon and the longer you can stay close
to your top of your game and being
healthy and all that you know in the end
yeah you might not get the stats and
everything you want this year but i
think it's going to pay out and be
beneficial for him in the long run
saints running back alvin camaro a third
round pick in 2017 still waiting for his
payday and
some believe that he's every bit as good
as christian mccaffrey he just doesn't
get the same reps the same opportunities
to generate yardage 2017 there was 1554
yards from scrimmage and 13 touchdowns
for camara 2018 1592 from scrimmage and
18 tds 2019 he dipped to 1330 and six
because of a knee problem he has shifted
to a plant-based diet chris for 2020.
the over under 1500 from scrimmage 10
total touchdowns i don't look you know
we we make a big deal about the
plant-based diet tom brady's on the
plant-based diet and
a lot of players it hasn't hurt him
right for camara what do you think he's
going to do healthy different diet over
under 1500 yards and 10 total touchdowns
what do you have and contract year and
really good team around him and
yes was disrespected maybe a little last
year and not brought up in the you know
top running backs conversation because
of that injury and he was tough and
fighting through it this guy's a
football player you know been around him
a few times i know he loves the game and
uh you know he views themselves as one
of the best in the game and i i'm going
over here i think this is a big year for
alvin kamara you know
one uh he's special he's healthy
you know with michael thomas emmanuel
sanders more being maybe uh attention
gone their way
and honestly too i think the time has
come for the saints to ride alvin kamara
a little harder too you know they've
they've had other running backs there
they've been able to give the ball to
but when healthy he to me is clearly a
notch above latavius murray and special
that way you know again i'm not saying
he's christian mccaffrey but i think a
healthy alvin kamara is not far off he
is right there in the combo
yeah and you know it's never been the
saints way under sean payton right to
have that one guy who is the bell cow
remember reggie bush second overall pick
in 2006 when the texans didn't take him
fell to the saints and there was this
anticipation he was going to be gail
sayers he never got the chances in new
orleans they put him in that that
rotation right with pierre thomas who
else was part of that oh i don't know
where is the one yeah right sorry you
know but reggie bush never got never got
the opportunities that we thought he
would have in new orleans uh and uh i
just wonder whether or not sean payton
is ready to put all the eggs in the
alvin kamara basket especially because
latavius murray
you know he he did pretty well he did
pretty well
as the replacement for mark ingram last
year yeah he did he really did and i
think deuce mcallister would he had been
there still when when uh reggie bush
yeah he was a he was first rounder in
2001 so he'd still been there yeah that
i mean that's crazy it really is now
i'll say this i think alvin kamara is a
true better in between the tackles
runner than reggie bush and that's to me
where you know yeah you said it latavius
murray's done a good job all those type
of things but camaro's you know he's a
guy that can do a lot with a little and
that's where he's special and for a
small guy
man can he break some tackles and run
with some power so uh i'm expecting them
to kind of unleash him this year so he
can get paid too
and it was deuce mcallister when reggie
bush was a rookie duke still had a
thousand yards rushing that year on 244
carries reggie had 155 attempts for 5.65
so not nearly the kind of explosion we
expected from reggie bush we'll see if
we get that from alvin kamara in his
fourth season in that contract year with
the saints mika fitzpatrick the big
trade last year from the dolphins to the
steelers in september steelers happily
gave up a first round pick and figured
out how to use him he says he wants six
or seven interceptions he had five last
year over under for minka fitzpatrick
picks six and a half chris what do you
have i'm gonna go under i am and i
listen i i love this player you know
he's a ball hawk i've been watching him
since high school and you know of course
watch him at alabama uh he he can do it
all but last year just
just right on the spot right there he
was johnny on the spot a few times where
he just got very fortunate that the ball
got tipped up and it ended up being
right in the area he was and he's got
great hands so if the ball hits his
hands he catches it but man you know
that that's a lot you know six seven
interceptions and to do that you know
back to back year i know last year he
had five and he had a number of fumble
recoveries too but yeah i'm going under
here i'm going under
he's a difference maker in that defense
he's a guy that i think that you know
i think the steelers secretly coveted
him when he was in the draft and uh they
they uh saw the opportunity happily gave
up the first round pick to get him and
and it's just he he just has the feel
already of a guy who's going to be a
long-term highly successful member of a
defense definitely that has quietly but
definitely gotten better and better and
better in recent years do not write off
the steelers in 2020 they are always
dangerous when the expectations are low
and for some reason a lot of people have
low expectations for the steelers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports